[MUSIC PLAYING]
PETE LEPAGE: Well,
hello everybody.
I am Pete LePage.
I'm a developer advocate
on the Chrome team.
And today I'm joined by Paul
Kinlan in our London office.
PAUL KINLAN: Hey, guys.
PETE LEPAGE: Hey, Paul.
How you doing?
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, I'm good.
Thank you.
Good, good, good.
PETE LEPAGE: Excellent
PAUL KINLAN: Had
yesterday off.
Now I'm back at work.
It's exciting times.
PETE LEPAGE: Very nice.
So today we want to about one
of the new Chrome Apps APIs,
the System Info API.
The System Info API lets you
access information about the
system, things like the number
of CPUs, the CPU usage,
memory, hard drive
storage space.
There's a couple of new ones
coming that we'll talk a
little bit about, including
display settings
and things like that.
These are experimental APIs.
So right now, they're under the
experimental namespace.
So as you're playing with them,
keep in mind that they
may change.
In fact, Paul you had mentioned
the display one.
I hadn't found that earlier,
but you found it, right?
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, I was
searching through the Docs
site that we've got where
I was looking for--
because we don't necessarily
always link to the latest
trunk at the moment from
the documentation.
So I was looking through the
search, and the search turned
up display settings.
And I was like, that's not
linked from anywhere.
So it's like so early on
it's kind of exciting.
So we're finding more APIs as
they come along, as well.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah, so the
documentation link is up there
on the screen, so you can go
have a look at the couple of
things that are documented
right now.
There are two pieces that are
definitely there documented.
There's a third one that we'll
talk about in our demo today
that's not documented.
And I'll explain a little
bit about that one.
But let's jump in and have
a quick look at the demo.
If we could bring
my screen up.
I'm going to bring up this
little app that I wrote
earlier today.
And we'll link to the source
code here in a little bit, but
for now I'll just show you a
couple of things that are
available through the
System Info API.
So first off, you can get
information about the system
architecture.
So what type of CPU is in there,
what the model is.
So you can see on my Mac that
I'm running here, I've got a
Core i7 running at about two
gigahertz with eight
processors.
I was trying this earlier on
a Chromebook to make sure
everything worked OK, and
I got a different set of
information here.
So you can see what's going
on within the processor.
I also can get the CPU usage.
So I know how much of my
CPU is being used.
Right now, the computer's not
really doing a whole heck of a
lot, so you can see that my
numbers are nice and low here.
Next piece is the memory
information.
Memory information--
I've just got this set
statically right now.
But it's showing me that the
available memory that I've got
on my computer, the maximum
capacity, and how much is
left, how much is
not being used.
So you can see I've got
about 8 gigs of
memory in this computer.
I'm using about 5 and
1/2, I think.
So I've got about
2 and 1/2 left.
And then, finally, the third one
is the storage capacity.
And this goes off and lists the
number of hard drives that
you have available, the total
capacity of the hard drive,
and the available space.
So those are the three pieces.
And then as Paul mentioned,
there's also the display
capabilities.
The display capabilities I
didn't get in here because
we're pretty sure
it just landed.
We can have a look here in a
minute and see if it's in
Chromium or where it is.
But let's take a look
at the code and see
how this is all working.
So I'm going to bring
up the sample.
And you can see on the screen
right now there's a link to a
GitHub repository.
This is the link to the
repository that I wrote
earlier this morning.
You can also go get
the one out of the
Chrome Apps sample directory.
That one, the code on it, Paul,
you described it well.
It's maybe not the best sample
code to use, because sample
code really should be written
reasonably well and follow
best practices, and
this may be--
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, we need
to get that one fixed.
I'll take full responsibility
in the fact that I actually
merged that one in.
So basically, this actual
system info API has been
worked on by some of
the guys at Intel.
And basically, it landed, and we
didn't have any samples for
it, so I went asking
to do samples.
Yeah, I was in a
bit of a rush.
And I checked it, it looked
OK, it worked.
And then we came back to it
today to say we're going to
show developers'
best practices.
Let's show them something
really cool.
And it needs a little
bit of work.
It's actually a great sample,
it's probably not the best one
to show off live.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah, so
we'll take a look.
Here's the code for the one that
I wrote, which is up and
available on my GitHub
repository.
But there's a couple of
things in here that
I'll just point out.
It's just sort of
standard HTML.
I've got some tables in here for
some of the data so that,
for example, if you've got
multiple hard drives, we want
to be able to have multiple
hard drives listed.
Have a look at my main JS, so
this is the place that brings
up the app.
Pretty standard stuff here.
We're used to all of these
normal things.
There's one that we don't talk
about a lot, and I'd like to
toss this one here.
This is one I think is really
useful to toss in is the ID.
If you put an ID into your
Chrome packaged app manifest
on the onLaunched call, what
that does is that'll help
Chrome remember where
that window is.
So if you close the window and
reopen it, or if you resize
it, it'll come back
to the same place.
If you don't put it in there,
it's not going to reopen to
the same place.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, the other
cool thing to point out about
that as well, it also acts
as a singleton as well.
So in theory, you can't open
any more windows now that
you've returned and referenced
the original window, if you're
trying to open the same
window twice.
PETE LEPAGE: Oh, perfect.
OK.
PAUL KINLAN: It's only
relatively recently that came
in as well.
So it's kind of cool.
PETE LEPAGE: OK.
PAUL KINLAN: It's kind
of nice, as well.
PETE LEPAGE: Excellent.
So in the manifest, manifest
is pretty much the standard
manifest that we're used
to looking at.
But there's one thing that I
added in here, and that's the
experimental API permission.
Because right now, like
I said, this is under
experimental, so we need to make
sure that we are asking
for experimental.
That does mean you can't
upload this to
the Chrome Web Store.
I tried to upload it earlier
thinking, huh, let's see if I
can get it up there so that you
guys could download it and
play with it as we're
talking about it.
And I was thinking, well, maybe
because I'm a Googler I
can get it in.
Yeah, no.
And, of course, my pet peeve, it
doesn't tell you until you
go to hit Publish.
And then it's like, ah!
[MOCKING LAUGH]
So, in any event, you need to
ask for the experimental
permission.
So let's go have a look at the
code that we've got in here.
I've just taken the system info,
created a variable that
I've shortened down to the
chrome.experimental.systemInfo
API just so that I would save a
little bit of typing and all
that kind of stuff.
And on my ("document").ready,
I go do a couple of things.
So I call updateCPU,
updateMemory, and
updateStorage.
We'll have a look at
those in a sec.
And then I added a listener.
So, like I said, there are
three different APIs
that you can call.
So systemInfo.cpu.get
will go and get the
information about the CPU.
Let's take a dive into that
right off the bat.
So I just do a console log so
we can see what's going on,
but I say CPU architecture
is CPU dot
architecture name, or archName.
The model is just the model
and number of processors.
And that's basically all that
we get back when we ask for
the GET for the CPU Info API.
So we get three parameters
back--
the model, the architecture, and
the number of processors.
The second one is memory.
And memory gives you the amount
of available memory
that you have on your
computer and the
amount of total memory.
So if we go and have a
look at updateMemory.
So systemInfo, memory.get.
And again, like most Chrome
packaged apps APIs
it uses a call back.
So updateMemoryInfo, so if we
go to updateMemoryInfo, sure
enough, here it is.
We've got a couple of things in
here that I'll point out.
So, again, I just do that
console log because I always
like to see when I'm debugging
things what's going on.
I say Math.round
memory.capacity, which is the
total capacity of my memory,
divided by 1024 by 1024, so I
can get it in megabytes, because
it gives you the
information back in bytes.
And then I just tack
on some megabyte.
And, again, same thing here
for the second line,
memory.availablecapacity gives
me the available capacity--
the amount of memory left.
So if we go and pop over,
here we go, let's
bring this guy up.
PAUL KINLAN: Does the memory
information update in real
time or is there a gap?
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah, that's
a good question, Paul.
Memory information does not
update in real time.
In fact, unless you specifically
add an event
listener, and we'll talk about
where you can do that in a
sec, none of these update
in real time.
It's just a single "get this
piece of information and do
something with it." So the
CPU information, memory
information, and the list of
hard drives that you have
available on your computer
are all just based on
a single GET request.
So you can see here that I've
got the eight and that.
So let's go back over to the
code here for a sec.
So then the third one we've got
is updateStorage, so if we
have a look at updateStorage.
Again, same thing, notice it's
systemInfo.storage.get and,
again, that callback that goes
and does the callback.
So if we go and look at
updateStorageInfo and have a
quick peek at that.
Again, for the storage info,
what I'm doing is basically
creating a bunch of
rows in my table.
So I go and grab my table body,
go through each of the
drives that I've got, and add
something for the drive ID,
for the drive type, the drive
capacity, and the drive
available capacity.
Now, one of the things you're
going to want to do when you
play with this as you look
around at some of these is
test this on a couple of
different platforms.
This is experimental right now,
so you want to try it in
a couple of different places.
Once we get this out of
experimental, I don't think
you're going to need
to do that.
The reason why I say you need
to check this is today the
storage info, if you request
that on a Chrome OS or a
Chromebook, it returns undefined
there because while
the machine has a hard drive and
storage space, it doesn't
really have the storage space in
the same way that we think
about storage space
on a regular
laptop or other device.
And as we move into looking at
how some of these apps run on
mobile devices, whether that's
a tablet, a phone, again,
that's going to be something
a little different.
So you're going to need to
handle a couple of different
behaviors in here on some
of these things.
Go ahead, Paul.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, I was going
to say just a note as well.
The [? type ?] can include
removable, as well.
So you can have removable
storage, so if it's a USB
drive, [INAUDIBLE] understand
whether
that's attached or not.
I'm yet to actually see
that working though.
But that's not to say it
doesn't, because I haven't put
the USB drive in.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah, so I tried
that earlier today with a CF
card and inserted and
removed a CF card--
and let me just bring up
the sample again here.
Notice how here it says
"harddisk." When I inserted a
CF card and refreshed, it
said "removable." But,
unfortunately, the API didn't
come back and automatically
say, hey, there's something
new there.
Now, that's kind of OK
because right now--
remember this was just that
single, one-time GET.
If I did another GET,
it would show up.
So there was no notification
because I wasn't listening for
anything at the time.
PAUL KINLAN: That's kind of
interesting [? enough ?] to me
because obviously we've got
the Media Gallery API, and
right now we don't have a device
attached to them, which
I think would be really
cool to have.
I know we were talking about
it a while ago, especially
with the [INAUDIBLE] work.
It'd be nice to have a device
attached to them.
And in lieu of that, you could
basically look through the
types of devices that
are attached.
Removable can say, hey, look
you've attached removable
storage, if you want to go and
scan the pictures, at least.
And then you can hook
that in with the
Media Gallery API then.
PETE LEPAGE: Exactly, exactly.
PAUL KINLAN: It seems like
a pretty nice way
to work around that.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah.
Yeah, and I don't think
it would be a
terribly hard thing because--
I'll pop into this right
now, if I pop
back over to the code--
if you have a look, I've got
this systemInfo.cpu.o
nUpdated.addListener.
So this says, hey, any
time the CPU is
updated, add an event.
There's a similar event for
storage that you can say, hey,
I want to listen for changes
in my storage
drive available size.
Now, I don't have that
one in here.
Though, let me actually bring up
a place where we do have it
so that you can just see.
Again, this is in the sample
that is up in the GitHub
repository for the team.
And you'll see here in a sec
why this is a little bit
frightening.
But startMonitor, so we
do systemInfo.stora
ge.onAvailableCa
pacityChanged.addListener so
that you can go in and say,
hey, I want to be able to
listen for changes
to the available
drive capacity changes.
PAUL KINLAN: When does
that change?
I mean, is that when you format
a drive or something?
PETE LEPAGE: That event fires
any time that the available
hard drive space changes.
Now, that could mean maybe you
saved a file to the disk.
Maybe the system has written
something in terms of like
some other app's saved to
disk, your paging files
changed size.
So it's not the most useful
thing right now because it's
going to fire left, right,
center, up, down, three ways
until Sunday.
As I was just writing some of
this app earlier, it was like
changing seven times.
So maybe not the most useful
thing, but still good to have.
So you can see here I've also
added a system info on updated
add listener for the
CPUUsageChanged.
And that's going to fire every
time the usage on the CPU
changes, so if I may be using
more CPU for processing or
something like that.
And that's why you get these
values here are changing.
So if I inspect this element,
and will have a look at the
console here, I don't have this
firing off right now with
each change.
So let's go and add that
in so that you
can see what's happening.
So update, update storage.
So here we go.
We've got the onCPUUsageChanged,
I'm just
going to do a console.log(info).
And now we'll pop
back over here.
If we reload the app, notice
we've got this log fire.
So we get the average
usage, and we
get a usage per processor.
And that's a list, an array
of the amount of
usage for each processor.
And I'm just doing a little bit
of math to go and display
these things.
PAUL KINLAN: Just a quick one,
we've had a question on one of
the Google+ posts from
Francois Beaufort.
What does Chrome OS is not the
same for storage info?
Can you ask Pete to elaborate?
PETE LEPAGE: Yes, certainly.
So earlier today when I tried
this on Chrome OS, what I got
back from the-- let me just
bring up the code here so I
can show you.
Where is it?
So here in the updateStorageInfo
method where
it's the callback--
so this is where I'm
handling the
different storage devices--
instead of getting back in an
array of the different hard
drives that are available to
me, I got back undefined,
which Chrome is coming back and
saying, hey, there are no
hard drives in this computer.
And rather than giving an array
of length zero, it gave
an undefined.
And so right now it's just
not returning anything.
Personally, I think that's a
bug, and I think we should be
returning an array of length
zero if there is no storage
devices available to
the application.
That's what's going on.
Go ahead.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, I agree.
I think it's a bug.
But at the same time, I think
some of the concept behind
Chrome OS, as well, is that
you should [INAUDIBLE].
PETE LEPAGE: Exactly.
PAUL KINLAN: It doesn't
make that much sense.
I don't know what it would be
like if you plugged a USB
device in, like a
storage device.
Regardless, it seems
like a bug.
Like Pete said, we'd expect
it to return zero, zero
[INAUDIBLE], for instance.
So I think that's to clarify
what Pete was
talking about before.
PETE LEPAGE: Exactly.
So if we can actually bring up
the link to Moderator so that
if people have questions they
can post your questions there
on Google Moderator.
We'll start taking those
questions here in
two or three minutes.
But the key thing to keep in
mind here is this is a cool,
easy way to get the information
you need about
what type of CPU is in the
machine, how busy the computer
is, how much memory is
available, and how much
storage space is available.
I think for the most part, the
storage space is going to be
the most interesting and most
useful to people, because as a
developer writing an
application, I'm not sure I
really need or really care what
platform that I'm on or
necessarily how much memory
is available.
I might want that information
to report back for analytics
or something like that, but
it's not really going to
change the way that I deal
with a lot of stuff.
One way that I might use it is
determining where I want to do
some of my processing.
If I'm writing an image-editing
app and I've got
some pretty heavy processing
that I'm going to do, I might
push that up to the server
to do if I've
got a low-end machine.
But that's going to depend on
a couple of other things.
PAUL KINLAN: That's actually
not a bad idea.
It's kind of hard to work out
whether you want to do things
locally or not, and it's kind
of interesting to see where
that's going to change with the
number of processes and
everything.
But, for me, some of the areas
that I'm kind of interested in
is you might be able to see
when a web worker, for
instance, that you have gets
pushed on to another thread
and you can see that it's
not on your main thread.
But from an actual usage, giving
it to users, they might
want to know how busy
their CPU is.
They're actually insanely
popular
tools on other platforms.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah,
that's true.
PAUL KINLAN: Just
to see how much
processing is getting used.
I'm always kind of a little
wary because by virtue of
using the API, it means that
you're using the CPU.
PETE LEPAGE: Exactly.
It's sort of that, well, if
you're going to measure it,
you're going to affect the
measurement of it.
It's always that fun
little piece.
I think there's a pact.
PAUL KINLAN: I can see a lot of
apps coming out like basic,
nice, HTML-based site, like
storage space site stuff, you
got the number of CPU processes
you've got.
I mean, there's a whole
load of stuff.
We haven't even got CPU
temperature in or a whole
other bit of metrics.
PETE LEPAGE: Absolutely.
PAUL KINLAN: I think it's one
of those experimental APIs
where we want more feedback
about what people want.
I know Intel wanted this
and to see some stuff.
But what do developers want?
And if you're a developer, what
you want, make sure you
leave it on [INAUDIBLE]
or leave us a message about
exactly what type of
information you want
from the system.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah, that's
a good call.
That's a very good call.
So if we can come off the
display and just go to the
side by side.
Why don't we have a look at some
of the questions and see
if there any questions in
Moderator so that if people
who do have any questions, we
can take some of those.
While I'm pulling that up, Paul,
is there anything you
want to add?
PAUL KINLAN: No, I think it's
basically this is still
experimental.
We've got the Display API, which
is kind of hidden and
doesn't seem to be available,
which, again, I think is
either a bug or it's embedding
Chromium [INAUDIBLE] trunk at
the moment.
These are actually kind of
interesting, if you've got the
displays, you want to know how
many displays are on the
screen, which window--
well, I'll rephrase it.
The thing I would be kind of
interested in is to be able to
target which window goes on to
what screen, because I don't
believe we have that capability
at the moment.
But if you can understand the
screens, the display depth and
the DPI and all that type of
stuff, you let the user have a
little bit more advanced control
over the layout of
applications, and you can go
full screen on one top or one
window or choose to go full
screen on a second window and
kind of keep the use of that
[INAUDIBLE] to do that.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah, that's
a good point.
PAUL KINLAN: Which is
what I want to see.
I don't think we're quite there
just yet, but this is
the whole point of these talks
is for us to tell everyone
exactly what's going down the
line and tell them how to
start to play with it
and also how to get
good feedback as well.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah, cool.
So I just pulled up the
questions, and the
link is there on--
hang on.
It's always fun.
It's somewhere.
It's right down there.
See?
You can see it right there.
So the questions are there.
If you've got questions,
feel free to post them.
I want to take one question from
a student at Davidson in
North Carolina.
It's not completely related to
the stuff that we're talking
about with the System Info
APIs, but I think it is a
somewhat interesting question
that definitely you could use
some of these with
Chrome apps.
And the student wanted to
know, "I'm working on an
independent research project
where I want to project a lot
of data, whether university or
hospital locations, economic
data, onto a map of the US.
What's the best program to use,
and what are some of the
Google API features that
would meet your needs?"
Well, I think from a Chrome apps
perspective for something
like this, we run into a couple
of challenges with
Chrome apps because
unfortunately right now, we
can't super easily embed maps.
Because the point of Chrome
apps is that they work
offline, and maps need that
online connection.
You can use a web view to go
and represent and pull in
those maps, but it won't
work offline.
That's probably the best way to
do this if you wanted to do
it as a Chrome app, to use
a web view and use
the Google Maps APIs.
And I know that they have
a regular show.
I don't know when they're
show is on.
I think their show may
actually be on in
about half an hour.
So if you're still
watching, check
developers.google.com/live to
see when the Maps show is.
They can definitely talk a lot
more about how to go and
overlay data and that kind of
stuff onto maps and where to
get some of this information.
Paul, anything you want
to add to that?
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, I mean,
there's a lot of other APIs
that we've got as well.
And whilst we don't quite have
access to what we know as the
Google Script Loader, where you
do Goog.load and then the
name of the script, primarily
because we can't
inject brand new--
well, we can inject new tags.
But the way that it does it, we
can't have access to that
at the moment.
But it's actually not too hard
to get access to the API's
[? expression. ?]
You can use the identity API,
whether it's the first-party
or third-party APIs.
PETE LEPAGE: That's true.
PAUL KINLAN: You can just make
normal XML and HTTP requests,
which are authenticated against
the OAuth token.
It's like two or three
lines of JavaScript.
And while we can make it a lot
easier to do, and we've still
got to work on that side of
things, you can still use that
to access all the existing APIs
because pretty much all
of our API suite is based off
OAuth 2.0 authentication.
So we have that built into
Chrome applications.
And if you want to go and get
some extra source of the data,
whether it's like a reverse
geomap, for instance, or
reverse geocode, sorry, you can
go and call those API REST
endpoints quite easily.
So that was my answer.
PETE LEPAGE: Cool.
All right, well it looks like
that's the end of the
questions for today.
So I want to thank Paul for
joining us from London and
thank you guys for watching.
Hopefully you found
this interesting.
We'll be back again next week,
same time, where we're going
to dive into some more
Chrome apps APIs.
Definitely go have a look at
developers.google.com/live to
see what our show next week is,
as well as check out our
Plus page at Google
Chrome Developers
is our name on there.
I'll be posting a short summary
of some of the stuff
that we talked about today.
So with that, Paul?
Do you have anything else
you want to add?
PAUL KINLAN: I'm really
excited about the
next couple of weeks.
I think this was the first,
probably simplest API to kind
of start to talk about.
We've got notifications.
I know people are going to
watch the notifications.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah, the
notifications are really slick.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah,
notifications, push
messaging--
PETE LEPAGE: That one's
pretty awesome.
PAUL KINLAN: That's
a good one.
What else have we got?
We've got loads actually.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah, we've
got a whole bunch.
In fact, I'll pull
it up right now.
PAUL KINLAN: We've got a
minute to spare, right?
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah, we've
got a minute.
All right, so if I bring up
google.developers.com/live.
It's great, some days at Google,
where you'd think we'd
have nice, fast internet
connections, we don't always
have the fastest of internet
connections.
PAUL KINLAN: That's because
you're using it to stream
video, right?
PETE LEPAGE: Well, yeah,
that's true.
So next week we're going to
be talking about rich
notifications.
So that's next week,
on the 26th.
The week after, we're going to
be talking about the synced
filesystem.
Synced filesystem, Paul why
don't you talk about that?
This is one you've been really
excited about for a while.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, this is one
of those ones that we kind of
need on the web, at least
especially for offline
applications.
It's the ability to use an API
that is basically exactly the
same as HTML5 sandbox filesystem
API, but basically
have better access
to Google Drive.
I think ultimately we don't want
to necessarily, like if
it's standardized, have it just
on Google Drive only.
But right now, it's integrated
the experience of Chrome
applications.
You'll basically save the file
to the HTML5 filesystem and
via the Google Drive--
and still sandboxed, right?
It's still sandboxed inside your
applications area, not
completely available
to everyone.
Have that file and replicate it
out to all your other that
kind of instances of your
application for that user.
So if they're on their MacBook
Pro and they save a file in to
their local sandboxed
filesystem, and then they go
in their Chromebook, well, it
will start to appear there.
And it will just be available
and synchronized.
So that facet, it's very
early on at the moment.
It's still experimental.
And there's a lot of things that
we're trying to work out
how we think developers
want to use it.
Right now, there's a collision
between the same file and two
different updates
on two machines.
The developer has to delete one
of those files, basically.
And we want to get a little bit
smarter about what to do
and how to kind of help the
developer resolve the conflict
and the collisions
inside files.
But that's one API to check out,
test, and obviously watch
in a couple of weeks when we're
going to show it off.
PETE LEPAGE: Cool.
And then the following week
we've got alarms, the
week of March 11.
So we've got plenty of cool
stuff coming out for you.
So stay tuned, and we'll
see you next
week at the same time.
Paul, thanks for joining,
and thanks
for watching, everybody.
PAUL KINLAN: Bye.